show me something time conference
championship weekend draft peter you get
the first pick
show me something josh allen and
as i have said 48 times in this show so
far i don't mean win the game what i
mean is show me the presents
show me uh the arm show me making plays
on the run
in the biggest game of your football
career this is when you make your uh
mark as one of the great quarterbacks in
the game
you've got to go toe to toe with patrick
mahomes on his turf
show me something josh allen
i'm gonna go show me something aaron
jones he had a good performance last
week against the la rams 14 carries for
99 yards added 14 more in the passing
game
they need him
to to move the chains
have that presence in the running game
take some steam out of the tampa bay
buccaneers defense you know point you
were making earlier about you don't want
them to seize momentum one way to do it
is just demoralize and we saw what
happened to the packers last year in the
conference championship game when they
were repeatedly demoralized by that san
francisco running attack the packers
don't quite need that but they need
aaron jones to step up and and
he's hitting free agency in march he's
got every reason to have a big game all
right round two
show me something alan lazard green bay
wide receiver
i just have this feeling in this game
that todd bowles and the tampa defense
are really going to try to take
uh devonta adams not take them out of
the game but really concentrate a lot of
attention on him so that he doesn't ruin
this game along with aaron rodgers alan
lazard showed last week that he can beat
a defense over the top he beat him on a
long touchdown pass after dropping one
earlier i think aaron rodgers looks for
alan lazard a lot on sunday
show me something you undrafted iowa
state what are they the cardinals
whatever they are show me something you
iowa stater alan lazard
cycle cyclones cyclone sorry got the
first letter right that's all that
matters first and the last letter right
by the way um next one for me and
show me something in dominican sioux you
know we saw him in the postseason run
for the rams reach a higher level right
um
this is a guy who's chasing what would
be his first super bowl championship
and and he's still got i mean he's his
arm still you know as big as my torso i
mean the guy's still big and strong and
there's that history with aaron rodgers
and i just think if he can unleash that
that force that we saw from him years
ago if he can get it together for one
day
that's going to be a huge difference
maker for the tampa bay buccaneer so i
don't know how much is left in the tank
for sue but this is a great opportunity
for him to step up one day one game one
moment and uh and help deliver a super
bowl birth to the tampa bay buccaneers
peter
show me something jair alexander mike
this was a guy who i almost put on my
nfl all pro team
when i voted a couple of weeks ago he's
had a tremendous season
and in my opinion he's going to have
chances to make plays against a very
good receiving corps and one of the
all-time great quarterbacks in the
playoffs the greatest quarterback won
more games than anybody in the playoffs
in tom brady
i think jair alexander needs
to bring it on sunday needs to make a
couple of big plays against tom brady to
make sure that that tampa offense
doesn't score in the high 20s or 30s and
come into lambeau and steal a win
my my next pick isn't show me something
it's show me anything le'veon bell
whatever happened to le'veon bell last
week two carries six yards three targets
no catches
look
not that long ago this guy was the
premier running back in the nfl this is
his chance to get to the super bowl this
is a chance to prove everyone wrong the
steelers the jets at any other doubters
and yeah first you got to get on the
field first you got to win the trust of
the coaching staff but show me anything
le'veon bell because he could be a
difference maker in this game for the
chiefs if he can get himself back to
being what he was peter uh not all that
long ago
i think the time for show me something
for le'veon bell is over so i'll finish
mine mike with show me something daryl
williams because i think he's going to
get the most carries out of the
backfield for kansas city this week and
look
andy reid has shown himself
in his history in kansas city and going
back to philadelphia he's an equal
opportunity
user of players
and if he doesn't see that explosion or
that greatness
out of le'veon bell which he hasn't seen
i doubt he's going to give him 45 snaps
on sunday i think daryl williams gets
the most carries on sunday so hey daryl
williams show us all something
i'll stay at that same position and in
that same game show me something devin
singletary with zack moss out the
running game for the bill struggles even
more seven carries for 25 yards and the
win over the ravens are going to need
more than that if they if they want to
have balance in their offense if that
chief's defense is able to take away a
guy like stefan diggs and otherwise slow
down the passing game they need
something more from the running game and
that has not been a strong suit of the
bills all year long
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports